showing his live stream in a mine
good boys
it's fine okay lovely and it's exactly
7:30 we'll make a start and welcome
everybody to watch for District
Council's remote review committee
meeting and welcome to anybody that is
watching via live stream and thank you
for attending this evening
I've thought with the agenda item number
1 which is apologies for absence we do
have apologies from councillor misses
hoy and councillor canal and there are
no other apologies item number 2 is
substitute members we welcome counselor
mr. hoy por council and mrs. hoy and
councillor Stanley for councillor canal
evening to you both non-member attending
councillor Smith welcome and councillor
Williams item number 4 which is minutes
of the meeting held on the 3rd of March
20 20 members should have a copy of
these they were sent quite a while ago
so hopefully everybody's had a good
chance to have a look at them our
members happy for me to sign a copy of
these minutes it will be a later day
obviously but it won't be this evening
but our members happy for me to sign
great great
thank you there looks like agreement and
there's nobody that's indicating to
speak so I'm I think we can say that
that's okay so that base minutes will be
signed Terry Anderson just for clarity
I've got a mouth shut because obviously
I wasn't on the review committee the
last meeting so I can't comment I can't
say all the way I don't know I
appreciate that thank you very much um I
- number 5 is to receive declarations of
interest which do include any whipping
declarations if you can indicate if you
have any I'm looking and it doesn't
appear that there are any okay thank you
I've to number six which is the treasury
management annual review 29 18 to 19 as
I think there should be 20 19 to 20 20
shouldn't it yes that right no me yes
I've just as the first time I've noted
it so it should that be change members
thank you for this item you do welcome
no me Lucas and councillor Smith and
hopefully members all had a chance to
have a look at the report that has been
circulated so as members will see it's a
fairly short and concise report and in
the usual way that we all right I try to
do things or maybe if I can ask Naomi
firstly just to run through the report
from it let's just highlight any points
that you think need to be highlighted
and then answer any questions that may
follow through members is that okay yes
one of three regular reports the review
committee receives and counts treasury
management activities each year so the
committee recommends the strategy the
treasury management strategies Council
for approval at the start of the year
then receives a mid-year report and this
is the annual year-end report which sets
out the position as counselor and said
for the 1920 financial year so the
report is reasonably self-explanatory
hopefully it sets out the investments
that the council has made during the
course of the year and including the
interest rate that those investments
have earned on average and the cash
balances that the council has held for
investments so members will be able to
see
that interest the bank of in Bank of
England base rate was held flat at
naught point seven five percent during
the financial year at their graphics and
paragraph three point three and you can
see from the blue line that the average
interest rate the council earned on its
investments which averaged just under
one percent over the course of of the
year so just slightly above that that
Bank of England base rate members will
be aware that rockford district council
has a relatively low risk and risk
appetite to its treasury management
activities so the interest rate earns is
usually fairly low and track contracts
the the base rate so at excuse me that's
paragraph four point one you can see
that at year-end the balance of
investments held was thirteen point
eight million and that was spread across
six million pounds with Santander four
million pounds with Lloyds and three
point eight million in a money market
fund so all of those investments in line
with the treasury management strategy
that was approved by this committee at
the start of the 1920 financial year and
this enabled the council to and just
over a hundred and forty seven thousand
pounds of interest in the course of the
year which is a bit above the budgeted
amounts of eighty thousand pounds but
that was mainly due to the fact that the
average balance is held by the council
increased during the course of over the
year and so I think that's probably all
I would and draw out from the reports as
I say it's it's then relatively
straightforward to report hopefully and
yes a the the the the annual position is
in line with the strategy agreed by this
committee at the start yeah so if
anyone's got any questions I'm happy to
try and answer them
thank you and I owe me for that and so
the members are aware I did I have all
some questions already forming irony
which he managed to answer some for me
as well counselor mr. Hoyt thank you I
didn't - councillor Smith wanted to go
before me or if you wanted to add
something - no mr. folk that was all me
yeah it's just a very small small amount
to add I think the report reflects what
what what is a successful year as far as
our treasury management is is concerned
and just point you to three three
locations within the report 2.2 you see
that the the operational issues
connected with the treasury management
are delegated to officers and I do think
that they have done well in this on 2.4
there's a statement of the standards
that we have to meet and I do believe
that we have met those and then finally
on four point five there's reference to
our advisors link asset management and
again I I think I have to reflect that
there they've served as well again so I
am quite pleased with the report and the
year that your your your reviewing thank
you thank you
councillor Smith counselor mr. hoy thank
you for letting counselor Smith go first
that's why Thank You chairman I believe
nyami's actually asked the question I
had anyway it was really I just really
confirmation and I read the report I
believe the strategy still the same as
it used to be and I just really want a
confirmation that there's been no
changes to the council's investment risk
we're still invested in the same sort of
things we were before and that hasn't
changed
thank you and yet the strategy we are
abiding by for the 1924
IRA's obviously being replaced now by
the 2021 and treasury management
strategy which was again recommended by
the review committee earlier this year
to fall Council for approval but I think
you should already be aware that
yeah the strategy for this financial
year did not change material at all from
the previous financial strategy treasury
management strategy so yeah there's no
material changes in our risk appetite in
the treasury management strategy for
this claim yeah exactly that's my
understanding as well
Thank You counsel Hoya and I only and
councillor Wilkinson Thank You chef and
very very quick question wants to ask
know me if I may this the for the first
time I've seen so in depth these sort of
investments the council does and I don't
know how on earth you've managed to
achieve such good returns because I mean
I know what I get off the remainder of
my lunch summon it's nothing like this
sort of return sorry sir it's fantastic
we've achieved and the hundred forty
seven thousand one hundred and ten
pounds naomi is that net in other words
is that after we obviously have to pay
link asset services for their services
so is that one hundred forty seven
hundred and ten pounds is that what we
have left over or does that sir there
but you have to come out from that great
amount of interest earned the fee we pay
a separate to that so yeah that if you
want you to look at it as a next
position you could subtract the fee that
we pay link asset services from from
outer space okay do you happen to know
what that is
yes I think it's detailed in the reports
apologies sorry so paragraph C so the
net position would be roughly 100,000
thousand pounds your lovely Thank You
chair thanks so much thanks Danny Thank
You counsel Canton thank you again know
me no other members are indicating that
they have a question for knowing me so I
think we'll move on to the
recommendation which is it
I was at the review committee resolved
to recommend the content that there is
pull the report to full council I think
they're all probably aware now that we
will have to go to each member and ask
for a vote in favor of that
recommendation or against and I believe
that's Sonia and if I had no visa Sonia
Sonia is going to to do the roll call
thank you so can you please indicate if
you'd like a recorded vote or if you
want to vote for or against Ain no
recorded by vote for Thank You counsel
Britain you meet you Jamie recorded vote
no and for the recommendation thank you
no mrs. Gooding well recorded vote and
for the motion thank you that's the
Hazelwood or do you want a recorded vote
why not and you want to vote for the
motion yep Thank You council hook way or
record your vote and for the thank you
notes not high notes the recorded vote
for the recommendation thank you answer
mrs. Macpherson no to the recorded vote
and for the recommendation thank you
yeah councillors is Mason motion Thank
You councillor Milne
for the recomendation
and no recording yes counselor mrs.
Pavlin plans sure no for the recorded
vote and for the recommendation
Francis Shaw no recorded vote for the
motion nice it's bearing no to recorded
vote for the motion has been a cancer
Stanley and recorded vote please
councillor Wilkinson no to the recorded
vote and for the recommendation place
thank you
Thank You members so I'm can you just
confirm I think it's clear that overall
the committee of for the recommendation
were there was a sufficient number of
folks reached her a recorded vote no no
that it no recorded vote there were only
two votes for that and the vote for the
motion was unanimous okay
Thank You members moving on to us thank
you
moving on to item number seven which is
the carbon neutral 5 2013 Thank You
councillor Smith sir I think that has
come through a bit delayed so I was the
number seven carbon neutral by 2013 and
for this item we welcome and Marcus
Houghton who will present the report and
two members in the same same way that no
me just has he'll run through the report
and highlight any areas that he believes
that member should be made aware of and
then any questions can follow after that
okay did you market yes thank you thank
you good evening chairman the members
the report essentially summarizes the
findings and recommendations of the
carbon neutral working group which was
tasked by four council to look at three
areas and these were consider an
understand cost investigate external
funding to consider how this council can
encourage developers design carbon
neutral homes and industrial estates
through a planning process and to
recommend a policy for this council to
consider originally by call 2020 but of
course since the codes coming on these
these timescales of slips like key
components of the report which help
shape and the draft policy and action
plan were the ongoing them of the assets
program and the opportunities that
present themselves in the upcoming
review of the leisure and waste
contracts these three aspects represent
the vast majority the carbon footprint
of the council and I would add though
that although these reactors are subject
to their own reviews so I'm not opposed
and discuss any of them in any detail
tonight but obviously that's a term I
think with the waste layers of contract
and the asset review that they're
mindful of the impact they could have
upon the carbon footprint and also the
opportunities that are there to reduce
that and make a significant contribution
to a reduction for the council if I can
draw attention to paragraph 3.6 and 3.7
within the report and reference is made
to the song submissions key drivers to
seek opportunities to minimize scope 1
direct emissions that's recognizing that
sources electricity are becoming cleaner
and therefore it's not a necessity a
necessity develop clean sources on sites
rather the ability to procure clean
sources electricity that can service the
council
therefore key thrust of the policy will
be to wean ourselves of the use of gas
and oil as fuel source and competing in
vehicles and the presumption that clean
and cheaper source electricity will
become available
in the near future there was also
discussion regarding the use of tree
planting to offset carbon consumption
and the report recognizes the role the
council can play however it should be
noted the in terms of even carbon
neutrality the government's has not
recognized as a tangible method is
offsetting carbon use when calculating
authorities emissions they felt although
tree planting with an open space we
actually plan for the contribution that
tree planting makes should not be used
as a license to continue to pollute the
council must strive to reduce its carbon
footprint rather than just offset
influence and planning process was also
looked into it was known as the best
opportunity to shape better carbon
neutral outcomes ensure the ongoing
Local Plan process the adoption of a
carbon neutral policy will add weights
and cooks incorporating appropriate
planning policy into the new local plan
references made to the Greater
Manchester Planning Policy and where
there is a clear aspiration target
certainly in that policy and the list of
ways in which that can be achieved in
very clear English all contained within
a single specific policy for carbon
reduction within the local plan so it
makes it very clear that there is a set
purpose for that policy the report
refers to a draft policy an action plan
where the draft action can't be seen
very much as a living document it
becomes clear actions can be achieved in
to do further if you like research and
feasibility studies into different
options that become available one of the
Magnum stations of the working group is
that the Brethren claim complexity of
the opportunities they're available to
reduce the carbon footprint of the
organization and take forward will
require a dedicated resource now whether
that's pilot Council or in a wider
partnership requires to be decided and
on that note [ __ ] drew attention to
recommendations and particularly
recommendation 9 on reflection having
some further conversation with potential
partners
it would seem premature to identify a
specific result in this stage and I'd
like to pose that wording to change to
read to investigate potential costs of a
carbon reduction officer or other
possible rate in such a partnership
working to deliver the initiatives in
the proposed action plan once
any requests traditional results we need
to consider as part of the budget
setting process the 20 21 22 and that's
really I think since we've written the
plan we've had third conversations with
partners and it becomes clear that we
probably have a different approach to
practice our own officer which in many
ways the recommendation constrains us to
at the moment I'm happy to take any
questions on the reform thank you thank
you very much
Marcus if I could go to councillor
Williams first good evening council
Williams evening Thank You chairman I
would just like to thank the working
group members of the working group and
especially the officers for this very
detailed report it's a very concise
thank you very much
I'm sure Marcus we have to answer any
questions required thank you Thank You
council being canceled Williams and
councillor walking to me Thank You
chairman I've just got a a couple of
questions Marcus if I may and the first
one's a point actually then a couple of
questions
the council decision that's recorded at
3.60 I'd really like that fully in
support of that and it brings the carbon
issue in to every decision or every
policy of the council mates I think
that's really positive a couple of
questions for me going back slightly fer
earlier in the report at paragraph 3.5
one the final sentence says however the
council's commitment to reduce its
carbon footprint would not outweigh the
national policy requirement to meet
growth needs of housing and jobs is that
the author's opinion was that the legal
basis in other words the national policy
would always trump whatever we want to
do so we can't move faster towards
carbon neutrality than the government
wants us to that's my first question the
second question is in relation to we do
I do want me to take them one at a time
Jen would that be easier okay I think if
we could on this occasion yes sorry if
you could just take that one that's fine
I will come back to you council gutten I
mean there's
a degree of opinion if you like in any
of these things in terms of its policy
and its planning policy so there's
always an interpretation but
nevertheless national policy will always
take precedence over over local policy
so in so many ways what we can shape in
terms of our carbon you try and see
policies you know local plan will still
have to be ninth mine through the
national policy first and foremost so if
it's not in a line and killed to a
national policy then when the local
playing is tested by an inspector it
will not be found to be saved so at that
point you know said so yes national
policy does tend to trump local policy
yeah no that makes Mary's perfect say
it's just going back on that before I
move on to my second question then
because and I and I will stand corrected
on this but my understanding is that the
that we are trying to achieve carbon
neutrality 20 years earlier than the
government is and which would indicate
that we're moving at a different pace so
if we are going to be moving faster than
them is their policy going to hold us up
right because I thought national policy
was that we're going to achieve there
won't be carbon neutral by 2050 so their
policy is moving at a slower rate than
ours would be you see what I'm saying I
do there is an aspiration I think for I
think they see a local of government and
Saudi government to achieve that target
before that time so the 23rd is more
about okay
thank you and chairman if I may the
second question is in relation to
paragraph 3.5 to final final sense that
says any assessment of the impact of the
road network on air quality would
include assessments at peak times and
would be carried out by an independent
consultant and we're all acutely aware
through our experience with the planning
Development Committee the the how Essex
highways Assessor or otherwise the the
impact on our local air and the road
network so what if the results of the
survey referred to in that final
paragraph
differ from Essex County counts or
highways opinion which one would win
I'm waited for thee to save these
questions up for a question putting them
outside the the breadth of this report
that so long as it slightly concerned
you know in terms of that I don't think
the outcome of this the policy of these
reports it's more the question perhaps
to to speak at a local plan review
rather than kneel if I money okay
no fair enough thank you thank you Sam
that's what happened
Thank You counsel Wilkinson Thank You
Marcus and counsel mr. Hawaii Thank You
chairman first of all I like to take the
working group they did a very thorough
job here and I think they pulled out
some very good good points and raised
the correct issues in many ways I just
do have some concerns that there I mean
there is a sort of commitment in
paragraph 7.21 on appendix E clear
commitment in the recommendations for
carbon neutrality by 2030 and the
council will hit all four others 2030s
the United Nations aim others think 2025
and many national bombers and after 2050
you write or 2040 and 2030 you seem to
be the the key otherwise the time of the
end of control there there is no
commitment for the new buildings for the
council to be carbon neutral I
understand there was there is
potentially an issue around the fact
that Peter has gone out everybody but it
understand from talking to a number of
officers that that that can be changed
there is no problem about changing the
design on the basis of changes that may
have occurred since the tender was put
out for instance that concern is there's
not any clear political oversight I
assume it would come under councillor
William Williams as the portfolio holder
for the environment but it doesn't
actually categorically say that some
counselors Damien porting Nathalie comes
under the lead or the deputy leader as a
specific item who every come
under it must come under a portfolio
holder or a or the or the leader or the
deputy leader I believe and yeah the
wording of their responsibilities must
be check must include the commitment to
be carbon neutral by 2030 as well and
that's missing in the report so it's a
little bit disappointing so I'd like
Clara Tionne who does have
responsibility for this on the political
level 1 1 7 I don't know if we're all
getting a little bit what's happening
really but the item 7 isn't there a
motion on the 14th of July around this
as well was that done via the working
group was that or come out from working
groups decided on the 14th of July
fashion council McPherson was about me
but the other one was almost weren't big
enough for that
ok community only got number 3 questions
yes thank you Marcus do you want to just
come back on that item 7 what are you
referring to you recommendations ever
nothing jump around to the pet let me
have a look at the recommendations in
the revised local claim takes into
account the government environment bill
yes I mean as well that's a separate
issue tonight I guess it's not something
under my control the the report this
stage Williams the portfolio who's
responsible for taking this forward I
think correct there's something it
pretty needs you made clearer in the in
the action sort of policy document but
it is sort of supported by thought
holder I mean yeah council woman's been
involved throughout the further process
and also had to report to Council
woman's on the matter so he's very much
him for him to oversee and because you
like politically responsible for but I
do take your points pretty sure we make
a little bit clearer I'm so those enough
another question there is well wasn't
wasn't quite sure if the other one was a
question yeah I might have made it an
observation but it probably was question
that why is there no commitment to
achieve carbon neutrality understand
that there could be difficulty in
achieving it but I always believe that
if there are no targets it's very hard
to move forward sometimes I think at
this stage we'll if we're being very
honest about this you know the officer
involved myself neither so I guess
professed experts on this matter so we
were luck to start setting targets that
potentially you know with no real
knowledge that we can achieve so I think
again this is a policy that like say may
well need revisiting over the years time
with some more set and more certainty I
think at this stage to sort of actually
say we can definitely do this this and
this with I guess a certain limited
knowledge of that of the subject would I
think I'd be very close to doing that as
well if that makes sense
okay that that possibly answers the next
question which was that some of the aims
are quite woolly in marking units you're
aiming where possible to minimize rather
than to set targets I accountant I like
target so I suppose that's my brain
counselor mr. Hoyt can I just interrupt
just for one moment
councillor McPherson is indicated to
speak I just wanted to check that that
was in direct response to Council ahoy
and cancel the person could you thank
you well yes then I can sir I would like
to speak as well at the end if that's
possible please but in response to
counselor mr. hoy
mentioning the motion at that's been put
forward for full council he is correct
it does include around the local plan
but it also includes another area around
lobbying the Secretary of State to
ensure that the National Planning policy
framework adopts the aims of the
environment bill which will obviously
help us and impact on future
developments Thank You chairman thank
you
Kempton the person council mr. Hoyt did
you alter yeah that's fine there's only
just
I'll make sure about Toby there was a
few questions around the officer but you
said that's being changed anyway the
only other thing is other councils and
I've actually Suffolk released their one
today I know they're a County Council
but they've released the the aims around
publishing an annual carbon budget
against target and I think that would
have been a good idea as well I mean I'm
not kind of a gangsta so obviously it's
something I support and however I think
there are three problems that become and
developed over the over the short term
thank you thank you and thank you
council mr. Hoyt councillors Barry
Thank You chairman Marcus has just
touched on one of these concerns that I
have and don't me wrong I'm not being
negative about the need to try and get
carbon neutral and I'm you know I've
been involved in certainly with the
contract regarding waste the
implications that we may face there but
there is so much in this recommend a
these recommendations and I I have great
concerns that we will have the resources
available to actually control all this
you know with due respect Marcus I know
what all the other implications are big
and put on you at the moment and there
comes a point where you cannot come back
well that's my view you cannot cover all
the things that are now being asked of
you
I think a resource and
one year employee fifty thousand Weber
as far as I can see if we want to
implement all these or get down on the
rope somebody has got to monitor this
somebody is this is got to be a job for
someone and there's got to be justified
budget in all the rest of it out of YC
there's just so much that it will just
I'm afraid get lost in there in the
ether along with all the other aspects
that we've got to address once we get
out of this coverage situation Thank You
chairman Thank You counselors Perry
Marcus did you want to come back on that
point yes certainly they're required for
a specific results I think I was just
concerned that I'd almost box myself in
a little weave through such a specific
request at this stage and they say I
think there's I think the working group
notes as well there's some fantastic
partnership opportunities out there it
doesn't mean they'll come for free I
think it makes nuwell be a resource cost
involved it's just the nature of our
schemes that results I think I'm a
little bit more time before I actually
come back and say this is what we
require I think perhaps we were only I
guess at the time so then we salt a
little bit so early on that one time we
asked the resource people and I think
they've been reflected in the amendment
to direct see recommendation nine hasn't
it absolutely okay thank you very much
I've got councillor Stanley thank you to
sort of obvious things that well I
haven't a dog with it I must admit I've
just scanned through it as always got
involved in this over the last three
hours so forgive me for Miss placing
something anyway Marcus that this is
although this has put together quite
well done there is nothing in there
that's where we are where we're going
with this carbon neutrality
when we say what materials we going to
go with apart from the housing which
you're speaking about as electric and
not using all your gas and that sort of
thing which I find that very difficult
but still can you are we as Boris wants
to add more houses built we are going to
use more cement and suchlike to build
these houses which is the which is quite
a large amount of hello know hello cats
with them yeah we can still hear you I
think okay yes so with as I said with
the idea of building more homes the
carbon neutrality is going to be very
hard to achieve even if we had go on to
electric vehicles and and such like the
carbon neutrality is going to be really
really hard to achieve I think in this
particular area where we've got such a
lot housing going on where do you see
our same if you like savings of carbon
not using carbon as much as there's no
report on there to show where you see
we're not doing air quality controls any
longer we've we've stopped doing those
so who is who is doing the air quality
is he a success doing it I don't know
okay yeah we can just take you there let
Marcus come back on that I think there
are some elements of the report that
that do cover some of the questions and
issues that you raised that I know would
you agree with that Marcus I think some
of them are covered in their they it's
it's a very wide-ranging subject this so
some of its covered in there yes I mean
in many ways they say again particularly
the housing we will be guided very much
by national policy so
and the our policy a council policy is
about the council cheaping neutrality
carbon neutrality by 2030 I think as a
district that's a wider ask than beyond
the existing council policy we're
putting forward and that'll be something
perhaps the local plan can look at but
they'll be governed by if you like
National Planning policy rather than how
the council sets out its own house if
that makes sense
there they're two different things two
sides of a coin a guess of anyways yes
thank you in what you say is okay I
agree with you there
so where do you find our carbon
neutrality will be in the council do you
do you see it as localized what you're
trying to I think what you're trying to
say it will be only what the council do
in effect of electric vehicles charging
points as more and more charging points
where do you see that yes I mean I was
just I think there is there is included
in the report councillors family
certainly parts are very included in
there but it because the topic is so
wild I think it would probably will be
something that develops over time
do you agree with that Marcus yes the
thinking was own house in order I think
before we start telling others how to
get there so if we can demonstrate we
can to carbon neutrality I their own
footprints then we can start say to
other organizations and housing the site
look it can be done I think that was a
logic behind it so the policy is very
much about looking at what the council
generates as in exactly that its own
estate and its own vehicles at this
stage thank you Marcus is that on to a
question counselor Stanley yep okay
lovely thank you the next counts of it
I've got indicated speak with councillor
McPherson if you want to speak now
Council
if you want to wait until the end until
the end of that's okay Thank You
chairman
yes that's absolutely fine so moving on
counsel and mrs. Mayton Thank You mr.
chairman I didn't know that we could
request an order of speaking as such and
so I would like a right to come back at
the end as well thank you I agree with
the concerns that being raised by
counsel staring at Stanley before I
actually speak the subject the officer
mentioned an amendment I've not received
an amendment I just double check my
papers
what amendment is he referring to
pleasing the recommendation I have got
here nine recommendations as far as I'm
aware they haven't been altered because
I have some very good that you can count
them mrs. Mason I know that the
amendment was submitted very very late
so apologies if that hasn't got around
to everyone markers is this something
you want to address or would it be
better for Sonia it's not on the council
website either mr. Chairman I think if
we have an amendment we should have time
to reap that and absorb it shouldn't be
done in a meeting
I think that's an acceptable okay thank
you
counselor mrs. Mason um some young
called Michelle would one of you be able
to come back to that I if you give me a
few moments while you sort of deal with
other speakers I can see if I can
actually project it on screen for if I
can actually you know I can type the
words up and show it on screen for
people to have a look at and under
simulate so that so that you are because
it is just a site amendment
one of the recommendations in essence
okay to come back when we have that
information it's rather hard to speak to
the recommendation when you don't know
what that recommendation is okay
compliment you later sighs thank you
okay no problem and counselor builtin
thank you and it was just a couple of
points and whilst we were on the working
group we discussed the potential of
continued meetings following this
recommendation is paper and just to
monitor performance really see because
it is a bit of a moving base there will
be changes to something because it is
such a broad topic and things will
continue to develop as we as we progress
and there's a couple of other things
regarding the amendment that you
mentioned at the beginning of the
meeting markets and I would say I mean I
agree with what you I agree with the
amendment you're making in that it
possibly is too early to commit to
somebody essentially full-time or
otherwise and whilst in my experience
people with sustainability or Carbon
Reduction officers on the council do
have better success is because we're a
small district it may be worth as we've
looked at during the working group
shared partnerships leaning on other
resources to get the absolute most for
our money our time and finally just to
remember that this paper and I think you
did just you did just touch on it it's
about our DC as an organization and not
our DC as the district and I think we're
straying into sort of both grounds
during some of the comments on this and
actually a lot of the recommendation I
feel do quite clearly mark out what the
plan is in terms of reducing plastic
immediately regarding the Bream status
of the assets and so on so I think it's
about remembering little about the
organization and not the area thank you
thank you Kemp the bottom just to
clarify in addition to the
minor amendments a recommendation line
which Marcus has touched upon and that
sanyas previously trying to get up on
screen for everybody in addition to that
there is actually a tenth recommendation
that is proposed and again there has
been rather late it's a proposal that
the recommendation that I discussed is
Marcus and that was that the review
committee doesn't receive an annual
update on the column neutral by 2013 so
it does become an annual topic that the
review committee and comes it comes
before review committee so that was
intense recommendation that is proposed
it's very short and hopefully that
members will understand the importance
of that council amel yeah my question is
really roundabout recommendation number
eight they talked about the
opportunities of working in partnership
presumably with the Association of South
Essex councils
I mean firstly have we actually ever
have we heard anything specific from
them at all at the moment or is there
anything leading in that it's coming
that way because it's in light the fact
that they are press release l or a
couple of the council's
about a large prefabricated building
plant being put in embezzled of area
which presumably is going to be the type
of houses in the BR eak Innovation Park
which may be 0 builds houses the ones
with the Selma roofs and the lithium
battery storage we don't know that but
they're talking about this outfit
turning out at fails and the houses a
year out of this plan but we don't see
anything at all in any of the releases
from the Association about any of this
and it may reflect on an approach
towards buildings at carbon utility and
the last point is at bre they not only
have carbon neutral buildings because we
took Sean Scranton and it's grew four
years ago they also have clinics and
public buildings examples a zero pills
so have we looked at any of this yet are
we going to in
perhaps in the next year as we go into
2021 that's just a task Thank You
counsel Emil Marcus did you want to come
back on that something we're going to
start looking at and we have included
any partnerships at this stage okay
something really we could look at and
review next year we'd like to see some
movement some look and research into
that thank you very possibly okay
members I don't know if you'll see in
the same thing that I am on the screen I
have a word document in front of make
another member see that yes chairman yep
I'll read it out just a clarity to
investigate the potential costs of a
carbon reduction officer or other
possible arrangements such as
partnership working to deliver the
initiatives in the proposed action plan
once quantified any requests for
additional resource will need to be
considered as part of the budget setting
process for 2021 2022 and that is the
proposed amendment to recommendation
number nine which obviously Barkers has
touched them why that amendment has been
has been suggested I do appreciate
counselor mrs. Mason that it is
obviously quite late in the day let's
come forward but um hopefully that on
screen will give members a chance to
read and understand what the
recommendation has been amended to and
obviously if there's any questions about
that then I'm sure we can we can address
those this evening but I do think that
if we had come to vote without that
amendment we would have been voting on
something in front of us which was not
the emotion that is there and perhaps
you could also give us the
foundation number 10 so that we're all
very clear what the recommendations are
that would be helpful thank you Thank
You councillor mrs. Mason I'm Sonya if
you could possibly display be okay and
that is that is the word in members for
recommendation number ten that the
review committee BC is an annual update
and carbon neutral by 2030 I think that
touches on Council of Belton point that
the review committee don't need to keep
on top of that okay thank you members
and Sonia are you able to reduce the
minimize that and get this screen back
as it was lovely thank you very much and
councillor look fearsome chairman and
may I say what a very good
recommendation number 10 there was a
magic council Macpherson sorry just I
just wanted to say thank you I know that
you were chairman at the working group
it is clear to everybody that the
working group has done a very thorough
job on a very wide-ranging topic so and
many things for doing that and thank you
and I I actually just wanted to first of
all thank my fellow members who all
contributed and especially the officers
who worked really hard on this inviting
other councils that we couldn't talk to
as well and the working group was of
course open to all parties and yet not
all parties joined but as you know
Belton has just indicated our meetings
will continue the carbon neutral make
working group will continue to run
and I've heard some really good ideas
tonight coming from the group's so
please can they accept this as an
invitation again to join and contribute
to the work in regardless pairings
coming around resources all I will say
is we have to find the resources this is
climate change and it cannot be ignored
thank you thank you chairman Thank You
councillor McPherson and councillor mrs.
Layton yes to me I am slightly concerned
along with councillor sparing of Stanley
that about the ambivalence of the
recommendation has been that the
vagueness of them however I do applaud
the actual ambitions of the working
group and can I ask for the problem we
have now is this working group which set
up under the review committee the
chairman of that working breakers
indicated that she wishes that to
continue however whilst is up to the
review committee to set policy and
recommend policy once those policies are
determined it is conventional for those
to be referred back to the portfolio
holders to set up their own working
groups rather than review because it
refused sets up the working groups how
can we overview and scrutinize which is
our major role those working groups I
have a concern with that going forward
I've got nothing but admiration for the
ambition that is shown in this report
but I am concerned about the lack of
clarity on some of the issues but I'm
more concerned about the fact that if
the working group is going to remain
under the review committee no one then
it would be able to scrutinize that work
and that is a concern that is our major
role Thank You mr. chairman Thank You
councillor mrs. Mason
I guess the setup could be looked at I
think it was almost trying but the
working group would remain and certainly
for the time being until I think
possibly that they were a bit further
along is that did the correct markers
have another poem there's kind of a
discussion I've had with Paul in the
past when there's that dependence there
is something to take away and speak to
counselor and Williams abouts as well
what's the best way and speak to Paul
well what's the best way of setting it
up it could be the working groups report
reports back into to the review
committee once a year but is actually
independent of the review committee in
between time okay thank you Marcus
councillor mr. Mason did you want to
come back on I can see you've been
dictated to speak not constitute like
the same working group under their
umbrellas and that can be done so
certainly it should be looked at because
otherwise we do run a risk because these
schemes are likely to involve a
significant amount of finance and in
some cases risk and we may need to make
sure that there is a mechanism to
overview and scrutinize any decisions so
I'm glad that you're taking that away
and hopefully we can report back on that
decision thank you
Thank You councillor mrs. bass I think
you raised a very good point
councillor Williams I can see you've
indicated to speak I'm assuming that's
in response to that but sorry yeah thank
you and I shall make sure that this is
taken up with by the executive in
collaboration with Marcus but thank you
once again thank you and that I'm
assuming that that's okay cancer
Macpherson on Sonny's chair of the
working group and you've also had a lot
of input into this but I think it felt
you're okay with that are you makes
perfect sense Thank You chairman lovely
thank you can send a person councillor
Stanley is the working group working for
a sole entity as as carbon neutrality or
are they working together we climate
change in other aspects Thank You
councillor Macpherson did you want to
come back because of that I'm not quite
sure what councillor Stanley he's asking
if he's asking if we're working in
partnership with other organizations if
they're off the benefit to rush a
district yes we will be I hope that
answers that I think that's perfectly
acceptable thank you Canton look
fearsome nobody else is indicating to
speak or ask any questions
now obviously members of senior original
nine recommendations are members happy
to take all of the recommendations
including the amended number nine and
ten in one vote or looks like the
general consensus is that members are
yeah I'm fine with that chair Ron
voucher okay that seems out that the
majority of members think we're happy
with that um just to reiterate it's just
in case it is not implemented members at
the moment just to clarify the
amendments of recommendation number nine
which will read to investigate the
potential costs of a Carbon Reduction
officer
or other possible arrangements such as
partnership working to deliver the
initiatives in the proposed action plan
once quantified any requests for
additional results will need to be
considered as part of the budget setting
process for 20 21 22 and the addition of
recommendation 10 that the review
committee receives an annual update on
carbon neutral by 2013 so as there are
no other indications to speak Sonia
would I better hand over to you at this
point just to take a vote for members
council speletons you want to record it
vote and if you want to vote for no
recorded by for the recommendations
thank you how's the Burton no recorded
vote for the recommendation Hansen mrs.
Levine no recorded vote and for the
recommendations thank you Nance no
Hazelwood for the recommendation and
suck way for recorded vote and staying
plants la hoy no to the recorded vote
and abstain counselor mrs. Macpherson no
for the recorded vote and for the
recommendations Thank You councillor
mrs. Mason
I think on balance against the recorded
votes and unfortunately I need to
abstain because of the lack of clarity
on it on some of the issues Thank You
councillor mill no recorded vote and for
the recommendations counselor mrs. Pat
Bailey recorded vote and for the
recommendations Thank You councillor
mrs. Shaw for the recommendations thank
you can special no for the recorded vote
for the recommendations recommendations
no Stanley no for record debugged and
abstain only recommendations cancer
Wilkinson no it's a recorded voice and
for the recommendation okay thank you
very much members and thank you Sonya I
think that the majority is for the
recommendations
taken together from numbers one to ten
and I believe there wasn't enough
members they indicated for a recorded
vote so that both won't be recorded
members thank you very much though sorry
okay thank you moving on to item number
H is the key decision document hopefully
everyone's got a copy to hand there are
two items on the key decision document
the first is referenced 2/20 that's the
modern slavery act 2015 my understanding
is
that this was sent or issued on the 1st
of July is that right Sunday budget the
key report was issued on the 1st of July
and the decision will be issued on the
9th 9th of July yeah thank you
and the second which is referenced 3/20
which is the voluntary sector grant
allocations decision I believe I don't
believe this is actually being issued at
all has it I think we've got an
indication it's next week it will be
towards the end of the month so that
will be report will be published ok
Thank You Sonia any members have any
questions regarding the key decisions
document at all okay thank you
and item number 9 excuse me which is the
work plan their members will see that
there are a couple of months which don't
have any items allocated to them as yet
and the proposal is that for these
September meeting we move the waste and
recycling item fleshie Marcos to the
September meeting and the peer review
meeting that the peer review item which
was a recommendation to take forward to
this year which I think was a an item
that most members wanted to see the
review committee look at in detail and
that proposal and these are any
proposals was to put that into the
November meeting and at the moment some
existing members of the review committee
may recall it in 2017 2018 we're
actually directly went to the public and
asked the public whether or not they
would like to nominate any issues items
or topics to review committee and we did
get one back actually we that went into
our January meeting so
my proposal is that we do that again
this year because I did quite like the
idea of that and hopefully it doesn't
help us engage the public a bit more
counselor mrs. Mason I can see you've
indicated to speak thank you yes yep uh
commune thank you yes so how was it sure
you say I agree with you that one
overdue ask for the review committee to
undertake is a full examination of the
aspects raised and the recommendations
provided by the court group be reviewed
last November one strengths were
serviced so our concerns in leadership
financial planning and viability
organizational leadership from
governments as well as the observation
that rots for district council needs to
be clear what it wants from its
partnerships including a seller most
concerning was the fact that the
overview and scrutiny was not considered
effective yet over 300 scrutiny of the
council's decisions and functions is a
fundamentally important role and we need
to resolve this whilst some of the
recommendations have begun to be
addressed there seems to be no clear
plan for this there should be I do not
believe that this should wait until
November it is too important as the
report covers all aspects of the council
perhaps we should look at one area at a
time as a way forward and obtain a
report from the appropriate portfolio
holder on how they are dressing the
concerns raised but this that detail is
obviously a matter for the committee we
should also be asking the leadership
team for their list what they see as
priorities but I think that this item is
so important that it should not be left
a whole year before we look at it okay
thank you back on our subject perhaps
action
leave you to consider bringing that
subject forward first certainly thank
you I have discussed it with with with
Sonia at the moment about the best the
most appropriate place to put it in the
work plan the reason we suggested
November is purely to do at the moment
with a the current working conditions
and the uncertain personnel watch for
District Council and and getting input
from them and the difficulty that we may
have in getting their input at this
moment in time that's really the reason
why we suggested November for that
obviously we can we can look at that in
a bit more detail we need to I don't
know it's at this stage Sonia you wanted
to make any comment on that at all or
come back at the end or yeah I've got
nothing nothing much to add at the
moment it's M it's just having the it's
having the the the resource and the
expertise at the moment in terms of
driving that forward appropriately I
mean we could we could try and sort of
finds that guess it in sort of slightly
sooner than that but I think at the
moment and there would be a danger of us
you know struggling to to give it the
proper consideration that it that it
needs okay thank you
if I can come back obviously common
explains the problems that the overview
of scrutiny has in that we are not able
to be effective in the time span that we
should it is a decision for the whole
committee whether this is brought
forward or not admit I think and report
that in November to start working on a
year after that the report was first
compiled is of concern but I leave that
to you and and your expertise Thank You
councilman whose makes and I do think
it's worth noting obviously the results
of the peer review one available until I
think at the beginning of this year and
2020 or certainly the last month of 2019
and
the review committee by then had already
set out his work times it was very
difficult to shoehorn that item in
essentially I totally agree with you I
do think it's important that the review
committee do look at this and I think
really just obviously in consultation
with Sonia I just feel that perhaps if
it's brought forward too soon we we may
not do it just this clearly because we
just unfortunately you didn't touch Ana
pretty good point but the resources just
aren't there at this moment in time
councillor walkins and did you come in
yes Thank You chairman I'm just looking
at the additional work that we need to
look at our notice emergency planning is
on there now
this we're obviously still within the
the grips of the pandemic albeit not
quite a lockdown stage we once were I
wonder that's obviously a really
important and an equally important I
would say aspects of our review that we
need to do and you know the the
emergency response or the response I
should say and the preparation that we
had leading up to this lockdown was was
was woefully inadequate and I think
everybody would probably agree with that
so
and that's wonder what what the thoughts
are with regards to when that might
feature because we've got to have a
serious review of mergency planning for
this council in case we end up in the
same situation again in 12 months of
time and I wonder what review is going
on in the background but we're not doing
that makes sense Thank You councillor
Wilkinson I think on the work plan where
it says emergency planning in the past
this has come before review committee
but obviously the planning previously
has never really touched on the subject
of a pandemic again having discussed
this with Sonia today actually the the
late councillor Terry cut more actually
in the March meeting did asks
specifically for the topic of closing 19
coronavirus and and how the council
responded to that and planning for a
similar pandemic happen in the future he
did ask for that to be on so I think
we possibly need to I totally agree with
you I think we do need to look at this
topic some more but I think perhaps
separately under the heading of the
subject of koubek 19 rather than
emergency plan image in the pastures
it's taken an awful lot more into
consideration but I do I do agree with
you is something I've discussed with
Sonia who I know that in turn has
discussed a bit and I think and I think
generally at the general consensus is
that it doesn't need to be reviewed by
review committee but I think I would
rather see it being reviewed
specifically under the topic or the
heading of COBIT 19 and the council's
response and planning for rather than
emergency planning if that makes sense
it does forgive me I didn't realize
obviously my first meeting I didn't
realize there was a secretary that's
fine a separate look at the Cobie 19 so
that's that's where I was coming from
satisfied thank you no that's absolutely
fine I didn't think that what that might
mean raised as a query and councillor
mr. Hoyer chairman um sort of questions
one relates to the one councillor
Wilkinson Oscar I think I need to expand
on it a bit more the first one is
obviously some members of this committee
are aware that there have been weekly
calls of group leaders and the
leadership team as in Shaun scrutton and
Angela Hutchinson's during the pen
touchings during the pandemic so we've
been discussing various things one of
those has been the Constitution which
which I did request to come to the
review committee and obviously members
would have received an email about the
Constitution and the rewrite or waiver
the rewriting of a new constitution
being induced and I assume any people
are caught in ideas towards that as well
however this I have been bold and
assured by introductions and Sean
Scranton will be coming to the ideas
it's come into going to come to the
review committee for the October meeting
to be reviewed with the possibility of
it coming to the November meeting if
there is any revisions or varies on it
so the October meeting
they come to the tribution at least
remember one as well that's the first
point okay if I could just comment
you're completely correct cancel hi if I
did miss now in addition to the Ripper
it is proposed that the Constitution
will come back to the October meeting at
the moment so that will be penciled into
that one apologies for that okay thank
you
and the second one I'm just going to go
back to the emergency planning and
resilient wedding
this has been raised for last three
years at review committee and it came
back in March and okay I think I I don't
think I did
Qwest a it's come back in the April
meeting particularly on the response to
the virus because it was as well as
councilor cut more I think this is now
moved on from there because I think this
is I think what's happened is you and
I'm not I don't to be critical some
things are done very well and I'm sure
other members of grey this are things
remiss but that always gonna happen I so
the emergency plan before as well
whether how good it was I think we've we
can now see how what or it was and I'm
aware that the council and this has been
requested by again but group leaders of
the council to do this is ask to people
what went well and what didn't go well
so that we know but I think I still
think this specifically does need a
review and I think it's probably moved
on from emergency planning coming back
with what they've done I think this
needs a more how well did emergency
planning work how well did resilience
planning work because resilience has
been in front of these review committee
and it was questioned then and clearly
there there have been problems in both
but there have been some things which
have worked him by us and I think it's
important the review committee do look
at this as a there's a quite an urgent
item and I'm aware that the council is
working on this because obviously we've
all had the email what did we think and
so there must be a report some there
being produced by someone which the this
review committee can look at and I think
we should do that sooner rather than
later because as
councillor Wilkins who said we don't
want to be in the same position a year
time not of learn our lessons see what
we did well see what we could improve on
and I think that's quite important we do
that as soon as we possibly can okay
Thank You councillor mr. Floyd and
counselor mrs. Mason I agree with
councillor evidence and to the other
councillors the emergency planning is
important and I think we've got to be
very careful here there's the emergency
planning as was which is for general
emergencies if you like yep now this is
the 7th of January we asked report from
the officer to come back to an update on
concerns that were raised I think like
all of us particularly I'm really
consoling this isn't personal myself to
the second of April meeting now I know
that since then things have changed and
we weren't able to have that meeting
however I would have expected the
officers report to be ready prior to
that because it was only a week after
lockdown so you wouldn't be expecting it
to be being produced so our concern that
wasn't done but that report now it
almost superseded by the issues that
have raised from the pandemic and they
missed once that the council has or has
not had to that so I would suggest we
split the emergency planning into two
one which is the existing emergency plan
which should still should easily be
available and put that onto the agenda
but we also need as Elsa who has sake to
look at our response to the pandemic and
I know someone commented it could be in
a year's time it could be in August it
could
in October it is quite important that
he's done very easy it became very
apparent that ruptured District Council
was reactive rather than proactive in my
opinion and this to mean it looked nice
we looked up with a degree emergency due
to the prevailing times there were many
exceptional acts and many officers have
done exceptionally well worked very hard
and gone over and above nevertheless the
structure needs to be there to support
them so I would suggest that we have
both those two different categories of
emergency planning so that we can focus
on the most important first before I go
I just will go on to the other thing the
other thing that I would like to be put
on the working plan is I think we could
want some report from the officers of
the leadership team of the money that
has been used by the government we were
given over 900 thousand pounds and the
council has received that through
central government and it has published
how it's been allocated in fact it sort
of the allocation seriously but I think
we need to know the reasons and the
rationale for that method of allocation
and I think that's a very simple report
that the review committee should request
and last but not least mr. chairman I
hope I'm not inundated you here last but
not least just a query again on protocol
it is customary for the review committee
to have an annual report which is agreed
one of the review committee and
presented to annual Council we have
annual council in two days time we have
a full house on the 14th
neither agenda is there an annual report
from the review committee which is a
surprising because we haven't had one
with sentences so perhaps I could just
ask for what's happened to that report
and what actions you're taking about it
thank you
okay thank you I mean I kept that item I
can't come back and address it was
something that I raised with Paul galas
several weeks ago when it first came to
my attention obviously it hadn't been
done one was needed unfortunately he
hasn't been able to come back but it is
something that I have spoken to him
about I would all speak to Sonia about
that I haven't raised it with Sonia as
yet but I will aim to do that possibly
for the next fall council meeting after
the footings to service the community
and those are concerned and perhaps
that's something you can think on and
take up in due course thank you
Thank You Kent summers whose Mason
councils Barry yeah Thank You chairman
couple of comments coming out of the
last few questions raised by members I
believe miss Lucas but could probably be
if you've been given notice could have
supplied the information of what that
nine hundred thousand where it is being
spent and how it's been spent I believe
that what was you can put out on the on
the website I'm not sure about that but
I'm pretty certain she has got that
information available with regard to the
emergency planning you know I would
suggest that while we the district
council was reactive I think the whole
world has been pretty reactive nobody
was fully geared up for it and I would
suggest that as I understand it officer
is obviously with asking their questions
are already preparing on a report and I
would suggest that either yourself or
Sonia liaise with officers to produce
the report and let us know when it will
be available to us say I don't think
that they want to want everybody to know
the plusses and minuses and I think
perhaps it would be better for them to
tell us when they have a comprehensive
report available rather than us trying
to
them a deadline they they're working on
it as I understand already so I think
perhaps I could be more be advising us
rather than us chasing them thank you
Thank You counselors Baron councilman
makes an octave indicate you did you
want to come back well aware that the
council has produced a paper of how it
has allocated them the funds and it's
also produced a revised allocation
that's not what when I asked I asked
this overview and scrutiny committee to
ask for it it's a simple report it
should only take a very short time to
ask for the reasons and the rationale
behind the method of allocation that's
all I'm asking for a simple report that
I'm sure that our section 1.1 officer
can produce quite easily Forrest and I
do think it's something we should look
at to substantial sum of money the
allocations have naturally changed over
time and they probably will again but I
think it's important that we do that is
our role and I'm asking for us to
undertake our role in a very small way
there I'm not questioning the amount I
know the amounts have been published I'm
questioning the rationale and the
reasons just ask how we got them thank
you okay no problem captaincies Mason
Naomi whilst you're still here at the
movement obviously you've heard was
counselor mrs. Mason has requested do
you think that would be a report that
you could generate a short fish report
well certainly don't get the impression
from counsel mrs. Mason either that
she's after an extensive report from
yourself with regards to how that's
being done and I think probably the what
she that the details that she's actually
asking for wouldn't constitute that
anyway is that something you think you
could possibly put together for a buta
to have a
and yes I'm sure
yeah I'd obviously want to liaise with
them Sonya and yourself to determine the
most appropriate format and and some
timing of any such and
rapport I'm happy to provide some more
detail I would suggest that it might be
more appropriate to consider that
towards the end of the year when the
actual financial implications of the
crisis are a bit clearer I think as some
members have alluded to the press
release and detail that we've published
already shows some indicative
allocations which are basically to
recompense us for any additional
expenditure incurred and loss of income
that we're expecting throughout
financial year but those s they are very
much estimates at this stage and
obviously are subject to change as year
progresses so I think any report that I
was to produce and you know the next
couple of months for example would be a
bit premature because it is based on
estimates and certainly obviously we are
open to scrutiny in terms of how we
actually allocate the funding at the end
of the year but at the moment it is very
much a yeah as I say very much based on
estimates and a great deal of
uncertainty still for example about
somehow some of our income projections
will come out and either the rest of the
financial year so I would sort of
lightly suggest that it be better to do
something towards the end of the
financial year rather than at this date
okay thank you no I mean counselor mr.
Mohsen
I hope that you're happy with that
response from Naomi and I'm certainly
happy to discuss that with Sonia and
Naomi after this meeting with the view
to the best time that we can we can get
that in and that will be on the work
plan I'm unhappy that we can't have
asked a simple report for the reasons
and rationale however if the offices and
the administration don't want to share
their reasons and rationale with this
committee we can hardly scrutinize it so
certainly I don't think a year is
acceptable but the end of the year to
you to instruct the other limiters this
I'm sorry mr. chairman I'm not happy but
I want to set for your decision
Thank You mr. Bozeman I think I
certainly didn't get the impression that
they know me or that the council are
looking to avoid providing the
information I think it was just taking
their advice went as to when it would be
most effective and most appropriate to
deliver it to review councilor Milner
and just a quick observation if as I
understand it in the legal how councils
have performed in assisting businesses
and individuals during this pandemic
Rochford council comes rather near top
of the list and the people did a
remarkable job in first circumstances
and that's all I can say about it at the
moment obviously get all the details
later and know that saying thank you
Thank You counsel obviously I would hope
that that would be reflected any report
that came forward and counselor mr. hoy
somebody the wrong buttons there mr.
Shaw's hitomi bottom I just speak first
it's just very quick could the section 1
5 1 officer just confirm when she can
produce the revolt because I already
imagine the if we produce the report the
the rationale behind it must be there
already so I thought it's quite simple
to do and I can't see why we would have
to wait that long for it this is the
report that castle mrs. Mason asked for
okay thank you counselor mr. hoy no I
mean that's something you can address or
answered at the moment the simple answer
is yes and in terms of projecting
forward what course we think we've
obviously Co incurred some costs at this
stage but in terms of projecting forward
where any cost might be throughout the
rest of the financial year and the
income
as I said at this stage if they are
based on estimates and any grant funding
haven't been sort of allocated as such
it is purely to recompense us for any
loss of income or extra expenditure that
we are anticipating when we set the
budget of the at the start of the
financial year so we do essentially need
to see how they materialize throughout
the financial year so then actually
allocate the grants to those appropriate
areas so we're not prejudging the
situation in terms of where that funding
will go but obviously we're we're kovat
has had an impact on our original
budgetary estimates were agreed by four
counts at the start of the year we're
looking to then attribute that funding
to to those pressure areas and as I say
at the moment because we're not clear
exactly how those will materialize I do
think it's a little bit premature we've
obviously published as much information
as we can at this stage about where we
think those pressures will arise but I
think it would be limited value and I'm
not sure I can add a huge amount more
than what has already been published
other than to say the grant will be
allocated where are those pressure areas
of rise and obviously there's still some
other government announcement some
funding and sort of in the offing as
well in terms of support so I think
we'll have a around the picture and more
comparative picture and as I said what
and certainly in a few months time and
probably you know towards the end of
financial year would be would be of more
value to members in my opinion but as I
say I happy to have that conversation
and with yourself as a chair and of the
members and offices if there's anything
more I can add at this stage okay thank
you now me I think we've probably talked
about that and enough for the time being
council missus makes it obviously it was
a very good suggestion I can assure you
that I will discuss it with Naomi and
Sonia we will discuss it further and it
will come back on the work plan with
every intention of getting it on the
work plan before the end of this year
and if we can get it on there any
earlier then we will do I give you my
word
counselor mr. Shah apologies for missing
you then and putting council high ahead
of you that wasn't intentional
you're muted cancellation saying earlier
I don't see the point in report it's not
going to be completed and I in some
places it's going to be a customer and
then the officer of them be criticized
for not giving the full report she said
they'd still be produced at the end of
the year we should accept that thank you
thank you attempting to mr. Shaw and
counter mrs. ice I can see you've
indicated to speak if it's on this topic
if we could make it fairly quick to come
back on something that counts the mihrab
said and many of the council's he's
right but the effort that watch the
District Council is made to give funds
to businesses has been exemplary and the
we have had three weekly - weekly
conference calls amongst the group
leaders and we've seen the amount of
work that's gone into that and I think
the council has performed exceptionally
well what members probably don't know is
that group leaders were given
information and we've actually gone
round to these businesses in our own
time to contact the ones where our
officers couldn't contact them and to
advise them that they are able to apply
this being a tremendous amount of work
behind the scenes and also other members
of my group certainly done that as well
and I think everyone everyone has done
what they can to assist and I think
that's something that we are not trying
to criticize here what we're trying to
do is to obtain information
to see if there's any improvements that
the I think we should have knowledge and
we don't Elsa mill for bringing that out
because we don't often have an ability
to do that in meetings thank you Thank
You councillor mrs. Mason and so
obviously I hope members can see that
the work plan will change slightly bring
you next year
we have got the Constitution October the
peer-review to add on the we will now
look at counselor mrs. Mason's
suggestion regarding the grant
allocation and the method of allocation
the we will also go out to the public
for consultation and we kept January
free at the moment for any responsibly
get from the public the topics there are
additional work items that members can
see that are listed there and obviously
we we do need to look at the situation
regarding emergency planning
/ko bid 19 and all our just asking
members just to bear with us at the
current time these items will be added
to the work plan I only aims with
unfortunately is something that I'm
going to have to speak to mainly but
these items will be added members I hope
that acceptable at the moment I know
that for some that it's possibly a
little bit broader I assure you that
they will be on there mmm no other
members are indicated to speak which
don't bring the meeting to an end but
before I do close meat and I know that
we don't have in any other business
section but I would just like to take
this opportunity I'm not sure core
members aware or not that Michelle is
leaving leaving us unfortunately at the
end of the month so just on behalf of
the review committee Michelle we would
like to thank you just for I would like
thank you personally for the assistance
that you've given me in and hopefully
I'm sure that I those sentiments are
echoed by all members of the review
committee that and thank you for your
help no thank you thank you
first lovely thanks for saying that
thank you
really Misha lovely thank you lovely
Thank You members for your time this
evening of I do appreciate you thank you
to officers for tending to portfolio
holders and Sonia again for the immense
amount of work you do in to help not
only me but other members I know you're
extremely busy at moment so you help as
much appreciated and so thank you all
for coming this evening and the meeting
closed